[Music]
drex here from drexfactorpoi sharing
with you the love of boy spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and brain
and today
i'm gonna give you a beginner combo that
is all about moving and all about levels
before we dive in i just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spinballs and ultra
poi for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all of these amazing businesses
and what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard elaine machinski
and becca beckham
thank you so very much for your support
for my work and my mission all right so
real talk my last combo tutorial was
really hard and i felt bad about that so
i wanted to give y'all something that
was going to be a little bit easier do
more beginner level tricks but also take
on some of the stuff that i'm playing
around with in that more advanced combo
so to that end i came up with something
that only requires three tricks
shooting today has been so weird there
have been a couple cop cars
trains dump trucks and now helicopters
overhead i think i must have just picked
the right part of the afternoon so the
whole idea here is that i'm going to try
and give you a combo that incorporates a
lot of the same ideas that that more
advanced combo did going back and forth
across the stage as well as
taking levels up and down but it's only
going to use three tricks to do it those
tricks are waist traps and more
specifically fountains which are really
just waist straps with an up and down
motion in them
butterflies and specifically butterflies
that go both in front of and behind your
head
and tuck turns
i'll go ahead and leave links to
tutorials for all of these tricks down
in the description as well as up in the
cards if you happen to be watching this
video on youtube i'll show you the combo
full speed take you through it step by
step and then show it to you again in
slow motion
[Music]
all right friends so the whole theory
behind this combo is we're going to go
from stage left to stage right
doing one poi trick
then we're going to go back from stage
right to stage left
doing a second poi trick
and finally go back from stage left to
stage right doing a third poi trick
and here we shall finish cool so for our
first trip from stage left to stage
right we're going to be doing this with
a waist strap and yes you may have
noticed i'm doing a chane step as i'm
doing this shania step is just stepping
forward with one foot
back with the other foot going along in
like what basically looks like a chain
hence the name of it
um in this particular case i'm stepping
back with my left forward with my right
back with my left forwards with my right
as i go around
and i'm just switching back and forth
between a reverse weave to a forwards
weave to a reverse weave to a ford's
weave as i'm going across yeah
now
the trick here is that you're going to
add some level changes into this as well
so you're going to take it up and around
the first time and then keep it down the
second time then up and around
that final time going to stage right so
it's high low
high we're looking to go from fountain
to waste strap to fountain which is kind
of redundant because the fountain is
really just a waste trap that goes up
and down now once we get over the stage
right here
we
come out of our weave we do a little
stall and we switch into butterflies
here
now as i go back to my stage left here
i'm going to step out and around i'm
basically going to do a grapevine step a
grapevine step is just
i step out with my left
my right steps in front
i step out with my left my right steps
behind
going along like so
now as i'm doing that
i'm going to go ahead
and have
my poi down in front of me when i step
out go behind when i step across in
front of me when i step out and then the
second time when i'm
stepping my right foot behind my left
i'm going to go ahead and bring my
entire body down so i'm going to cut a
very
dramatic profile with this and of course
come out here to stop over at stage left
with my two poi at my sides i'm just
going to let the momentum from the
butterflies come to an end now i'm going
to go back to stage right i'm going to
do this i'm going to swing both poi
around i'm going to go over my shoulders
under my shoulders over my shoulders
under my shoulders that's right it's the
sun i step once again and as i come over
here to stage right i'm going to kneel
down as the poi drop behind my shoulders
adding one more level change into this
combo
so
that's all the pieces let me show you
that again from the top so starting over
here on stage left i'm going to take
my waist strap around in a fountain
going over
down
over
stop i'm going to step out one
two
one two and stop then i'm gonna switch
into my chuck turns going over under
over
under
under and stop
with the poi falling behind my shoulders
as i crouch down yeah
awesome let's see that again in slo-mo
[Music]
levels turns traveling side to side cats
and dogs
living together mass hysteria
but for real though i'd love to see
y'all take this one on uh go ahead and
shoot video of yourself working on this
combo put it up on the social media
platform of your choice and tag me i'm
at drexfactor on most social media
platforms i'd love to see your hard work
please show it to me thank you
[Music]
if you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
it as well as to help my channel grow
this video would not have been possible
without the kind support of all of these
nice people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with down in the description
do you like my videos do you like my
combo tutorials my flow videos my vlogs
etc i'm on a mission to try and bring
poi spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that either at the link down in the
description or the card that just popped
up if you are watching on youtube there
you can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission here
thank you for checking that out and
thank you to all of you who support this
channel already do you have a trick that
you'd like to see me integrate into a
combo transition between two tricks that
you're really struggling with leave me a
comment and let me know and i will see
what i can do about putting together a
combo just for you
um in the meantime go ahead and check
out some other combo tutorials i've done
at the link down in the description or
the little
window that's popped up on screen here
if you're watching on youtube make sure
you get outside the flow this weekend
with a new video on monday thanks for
watching